hi leute ich es wieder eure mal panne
und thomas und henry ich war eigentlich
immer der meinung dass ich ein super
kind war gut informiert gut in der
schule intelligent selbst reflektiert
das alles was einen guten menschen aus
mach ich habe zwei tagebücher von mir
gefunden und die dinge die ich bis jetzt
darin gelesen habe die sind alles andere
als over messer du warst so intelligent
und mensch was du ein tolles kind nein
fangen wir an mit meinem allerersten
tagebuch ipad spielen also ein kleines
märchen vorne drauf legen wir los
das steht anfang fünfter november 2004
das ist einfach mal im november sind das
12 jahre ich war elf als ich das
angefangen habt also an alle elfjährigen
wie das jetzt gerade sehen ich war zu
dem zeitpunkt elf vielleicht erinnern
sich die anderen ja auch daran wie sie
mit elf waren vielleicht kann ich damit
ein bisschen vergleichen ich hoffe aber
lieber nicht wissen wir mal den ersten
eintrag liebes tagebuch heute ist
freitag ich bin am morgen mit
ann-christin es ist meine beste freundin
zur schule gefahren es ist viel besser
hinten zu sitzen denn wenn man etwas in
mathe nicht weiß kann man die jungs
fragen und macht das ist antifeminismus
die jungs können besser matte
statistisch gesehen können sie glaube
ich auch aber egal abends ist wie immer
fernseher zeit dass bald alles ist wie
immer fernseher zeit da habe ich aber
noch bewusstes fernseher heißt weil
jetzt sage ich mir mittlerweile
fernsehen oder fernsehen läuft noch wir
müssen den fernsehen ausschalten 2004
wusste ich dass noch was ist bloß
passiert ja typisch weit jetzt kommt der
spannende neue name für meinen tagebuch
rexer elfter 2004 ich glaube ab jetzt
nenne ich dich teddy und nicht tagebuch
weltkrieg ich taschengeld bis bald habe
ich jemals taschengeld bekommen ich habe
nie taschengeld bekommt ganz ganz selten
habe ich mal geld bekommen wenn ich
irgendwo hingehen wollte das war dann
immer so wenig dass sich
anderen viel mehr leisten konnte
natürlich machen wir mal weiter siebter
elfter hallo teddy heute war nichts
besonderes los ich habe sehr viel
gelesen
morgen ist schule juhu das wochenende
war so langweilig warum hat das
wochenende nicht genossen du dor in los
ich glaube dass ich an christin auch ein
stift schenke informationen christoph
ist so blöd er will immer kämpfen
richtig ernst dann kann ich mich sogar
noch hinter meinem bruder wollte immer
wie bei wwe wrestler heute auch mal
kämpfen so elfter elfter oder sind schon
paar tage dazwischen heidi bei uns zu
hause ist gerade stress doch in der
schule ist es klasse ich rede viel öfter
schon mit marvin ich verliebe mich immer
mehr in ihn
jetzt weiß ich nicht ob ich alina das
erzählen soll das mit dem computer was
mit dem computer was euch getan was ist
mit dem computer deshalb wie sushi was
passiert lina habe ich dir das jemals
für den computer erzählt
heute war der tag lasse wohl heute mit
bohrens erst habe ich und franzi maren
gejagt und danach war nachmittag in der
schule als wir gerade beispiele verleih
waren ist maren gekommen und jenny hat
die ganze zeit gerufen
vanessa ist in marvel später hat jenny
marvin gefragt ob er und andré mit uns
und jenny ins kino gehen will
eigentlich bin ich ja mit in marvin und
julien andré aber irgendwie sagt jenny
dass sie jetzt auch einfach ist und gott
und morgen sagt maren uns in wien
andré ist hoffentlich in jenny bitte
nicht in mich dann bist bald ich gebe
dir über alles bescheid
ich dachte ich war cool ich dachte ich
hab so ein scheiß auf jungs gegeben und
habe mein ding gemacht nein ich war so
eine blöde und jungs jugend robert ist
in wenigen aber egal ich glaube ich lese
noch ein zwei sachen vor sie monster
2000 plätzen hallo
gestern war weihnachtsbasar jenny andré
sind rumgelaufen haben kicker gespielt
ab und zu kam dann auch marvin jenny war
eifersüchtig dass ich mit anderen
gespielt habe ich liebe doch marvin
morgen gehen wir ins kino
ich freue mich schon ich sag dir dann
wie es war wie gesagt ich wie es war
bitte bitte bitte bedeutet natürlich
hast du nicht gestimmt dies war hatte
die entschuldigung dass ich dir gestern
nicht geschrieben habe wir haben sieben
zwerge gesehen
es war sehr schön erinnert ihr euch noch
an sieben zwerge man darf ins kino
gegangen um den film zu gucken danach
waren wir bei anderen haben pkw action
gespielt es war toll marvin hat mich und
ich ihn geküsst aber nur auf die wange
heute haben wir kicker gespielt vanessa
du bist aber rang könnt ihr euch noch an
pkw action erinnern spielt beim pkw
action heute nur bei pkw cover küssen
pins weber wahrheit pupsen und action
was machen habt ihr es auch pkw action
genannt anderen encino wahrheit oder
pflicht wird ein pkw action haben wir
geschrieben wilden hasen und marvin hat
mich auf die wange geküsst okay einen
letzten noch zum abschied 23 12 2014
heidi morgen ist weihnachten ich freue
mich schon sehr heute habe ich kekse
gebacken
am mittwoch war ich verzweifelt denn ich
musste mich entscheiden ob ich mit
marvin zusammen sein würden ich weiß es
nicht
ich wünsche dir frohe weihnachten du
liebst die vermesser was tust du da erst
schreiben ich liebe morgen ich liebe
haben und dann bist du was ich höre an
dieser stelle auf und wir schauen ob ich
mich für marvin entschieden habe das
seht ihr dann in der nächsten folge von
dieses video woche im format titelstory
teil
bis dann ich hab gerade das video
channel geschnitten und da ist mir
aufgefallen natürlich gar nicht jeder
dass ich bei jakab damit zu besuch war
also wenn ihr mich kochen sehen wollt
mit felix zusammen ein polnisches
gericht dann geht man auf dem land am
kanal und schaut wie gut ich kochen
ja